Here's the efficient solution.
The trick is that we're
going to use recursion.
And I'm not going to show you
something called the trellis diagram,
which is a, a way of thinking
about a graph model of this.
But what we're going to take advantage
of, remember the Markovian property?
The Markovian property says that
the probability of going to some state
only depends upon where I am now.
It does not depend upon how I got here.
Right?
So
if today is sunny,
the probability of tomorrow being sunny
is not affected by whether yesterday
was rainy, snowy, or sunny.
That's my assumption.
That's my first-order
Markovian assumption.
So to take advantage of that, we're
going to define some auxiliary variables
and define a recursive algorithm.
So the first thing we're going to
define is what's called the forward
variable alpha.
Okay, an alpha sub t
of i is defined to be
the probability of seeing all
the observations up until time t,
and at time t being in state i.
Okay?
That's exactly what
it says in this book.
In well,
now there's a box inside the box there.
So it's the probability of seeing
everything from 1 until t and
being at in type t being in state i.
The really cool thing about that is,
I can define a recursive definition for
this very easily.
All right, so
you start off a1 of i is what?
Well it's the probability of having
seen the observation at time 1 and
the probability of being
in state i at time 1.
Okay, well that's easy.
Pi sub i is the probability of
starting in state i, and b i of o1,
is the probability of seeing that
first symbol if you were in state i.
So that's how you initialize it.
Now comes the really re, cool thing,
and before we write it out,
think about it this way.
At some time t, the probability of
landing in state j is going to be,
well, either I was in state 1 before and
I ended up at state J or
I was in 2 before or
I was in 3 before or I was in 4 before.
Right?
And these are what are referred
to as mutually exclusive, so
the probability is just the sum of them.
And that's how this is written here,
right?
What this says is that
alpha of t plus 1 of j.
So that's the probability at
time t plus 1 of being in state
j and having seen all the 1
to t plus 1 observations.
Is just, well, just as I said before,
it's the sum over all the different
possible states, right?
There's n possible states of possibly
being in those states at time t.
That's what alpha t is, right?
And alpha t also includes all of
the observations, up through t,
times the transition probability
of going from i to j.
Remember, we're trying to
compute alpha t plus 1 of j.
Going from i to j.
So that's the probability
that I land in this state, j.
And now, I also have to talk about
the output symbol, at time t plus 1.
Well, that's b sub j of ot plus 1.
All right?
And
there's no way of thinking
that I can reach that j
state from any of the preceding states.
So I just define that recursively.
That means I can do one
more really cool thing.
Okay?
So I could obviously run
this all the way to t.
So I could tell you the probability
of seeing all of the observations,
1 through cap t, and landing in state 1.
And all the observations and
landing in state 2, and landing is,
suppose all I want is the probability
of the observations, right.
I don't actually care
what state I end up in.
Well that means that the probability of
the observation given the machine and
that's what we're trying to compute,
is just the sum of all
the alpha cap T of I's, right?
Alpha cap t is the probability of seeing
all of the sequence, of i meaning and
landing in state i.
I sum that up over all the i's, and
that's the probability of
the entire observation sequence.
So you recursively solve that problem.
So remember before it was n to the t,
which is a really,
really awful number, the complexity
of this is just n squared t.
Okay?
Through the, the recursion.
Each time step, you have n squared
things you have to look at,
you do it t times and
so it's n squared t.
And for any reasonable numbers,
n squared t is way, way, way,
way less than n to the t.
All right?
So, that's that efficient
solution of the forward,
using the forward algorithm and allows
us to recover, solve that first problem.